au venezuela l'opposition annoncé se
retirer des élections législatives un
scrutin qualifié de farce électorale par
des représentants de onze formations
politiques
dans un communiqué ils dénoncent une
manoeuvre de nicolás maduro
vendredi le tribunal suprême de justice
a nommé deux nouveaux membres à la tête
du conseil national électoral
un conseil chargé de superviser le
scrutin qui aura lieu dans le rang de
l'année et pour en parler nous sommes
avec farid fernandez ancien diplomate et
consultant amérique latine farid
fernandez merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors l'opposition
on se souvient avait gagné les élections
législatives de décembre 2015 remportant
112 des 167 sièges du parlement
n est ce pas un pari risqué pour
l'opposition de boycotter les
législatives
tout à fait alors je pense qu'il faut
replacer un petit peu le contexte le
venezuela n'est pas une dictature c'est
plutôt une une démocratie
dysfonctionnelle on a d'une part une
opposition qui dont le leader est le
dirigeant et ron wood lui qui représente
les factions les plus radicales de cette
opposition main pour partie peu
respectueuse de certaines traditions
démocratiques ou en tout cas qui ne
rejette pas les solutions violentes à
principe on a vu l'année dernière on a
pris en avril 2019 un coup d'état dirigé
par lui-même en avant en mai de cette
année une tentative de de l'opération
par des mercenaires d'une organisation
silver corp et aux essais y ont voient
donc une opposition qui ne qui n'est pas
homogène qui est fissurée et la
stratégie du président maduro qui vise
finalement 1 à mettre en lumière ses
divisions pour pour pour isoler ces
factions les plus radicales et les moins
démocratiques est une opération qui peut
avoir un succès dans le sens où une
partie de l'opposition on le voit
aujourd'hui est tenté par un retour aux
urnes et par une participation à ces
élections
alors du côté de nicolás maduro et ses
partisans ont justement comment ce
boycott de l'opposition est il perçu
alors le cha li ce n'est pas homogène
non plus on voit c'est un cetain la
polarisation politique ces dernières
années au venezuela a radicalisé chaque
camp mais dans chaque camp également
l'un des modérés qui réclame un dialogue
qui puisse répondre à cette paralysie
politique dans laquelle se situe le
délai zola aujourd'hui puisque
évidemment aujourd'hui un appel est fait
par le chavisme à l'opposition pour
qu'elle revienne dans lequel accepte le
jeu les élections et l'enjeu aujourd'hui
sera de voir dans chaque camp les voies
qui peuvent s'élever pour réclamer un un
dialogue et une sortie de cette impasse
alors l'opposition qui a qualifié de
farce le scrutin qu'est ce que reproche
très concrètement cette opposition
vénézuélienne dans l'organisation de ces
élections
alors elle reproche le fait que le
conseil national électoral qui est
l'organe chargé de l'organisation de ces
élections n'ayant pas été nommé par
l'assemblée nationale a été nommé par la
cour suprême le tribunal suprême de
justice
or ce n'est pas la première fois il est
prévu au venezuela que lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de consensus où les la majorité
qualifiée des deux tiers à l'assemblée
nationale pour élire ses nouveaux
membres
il est prévu de recourir au tribunal
suprême de justice a été quatre fois été
le cas dans le passé
et d'ailleurs l'opposition guido lui
même a été élu par un conseil national
électoral qui avait été avalée avalisée
par le tribunal suprême de justice donc
il s'agit d'un débat juridique le
problème en hongrie il ne doit pas être
sur ce sur cette place est sur cet angle
là il s'agit à mon avis d'une concorde
vénézuélienne aujourd'hui dont il est
nécessaire il est nécessaire que
effectivement il ya des divergences très
profondes entre l'opposition et le
chavisme mai
il serait souhaitable aujourd'hui que 1
des espaces soient créées pour que
puisse discuter des représentants des
deux bords et se mettre d'accord sur des
principes élémentaires de la vie aux
communes dans la vie en commun de la
coexistence démocratique au sein de
d'une société très divisé et très
fractionnée ce dialogue
comment est il possible finalement c'est
jouable encore aujourd'hui pour les deux
parties de se parler tout à fait oui je
l'adage ceux des log a lieu ce dialogue
a lieu même si certains dirigeants des
deux camps ne veulent pas y participer
ce délai les lieux il est il a lieu au
venezuela au sein de la société civile
il a lieu aussi de manière plus discrète
à un haut niveau international des
représentants des deux camps font partie
de ce cercle formel ou informel de
discussions pour arriver à trouver une
solution au problème qui aujourd'hui ont
mis le venezuela non seulement dans une
espace politique mais dans une crise
économique et sociale majeure avec on
l'a vue d une inflation galopante une
crise économique qui impacte grandement
la majeure partie des populations
justement cette crise économique et
sociale que vous venez d'évoquer en quoi
cette crise politique un risque t'elle
d'aggraver encore plus la situation dans
les prochains mois le problème
principalement et la mise du venezuela
sous quasi embargo de la part des états
unis avec des sanctions qui affecte son
industrie pétrolière et empêche le
venezuela de pouvoir exporter disons sa
ressource principale qui est depuis
presque presque un siècle l'or noir les
eaux l'air disposent des principales
ressources sauver en hydrocarbures au
monde et ne peut pas aujourd'hui
librement disposer cette richesse sur le
marché international l'enjeu aujourd'hui
effectivement de pouvoir rétablir un
dialogue démocratique avait les allées
entre toutes les parties la population
que tout accepte ou en tout cas une
marge heures partie d'entre elles de
revenir aux urnes à la fin de l'année
pour renouveler cette assemblée
nationale pour ensuite ouvrir la voie
vers espérons le un allègement de ses
sanctions l'un qui permettra au
venezuela de faire redémarrer une
économie qui a perdu qui a diminué de
moitié au cours des six dernières années
mais
si beaucoup farid fernandez d'avoir
partagé votre analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien diplomate et consultant
sur l'amérique latine
merci